>>Male Presenter: Good afternoon, Googlers!
Welcome to Authors @ Google, Cambridge edition.
It's my great pleasure to introduce to you
today Beatrice Peltre who I had the honor
of working with years ago at a different software
company.
Since then she has parlayed her passion for
food and cooking into an amazing career as
a blogger, food photographer, food stylist,
and now best-selling cookbook author.
This book is outselling Jacques Pepin and
Julia Child at this moment and—
>>Beatrice: Right now.
>>Male Presenter: Not now?
>>Beatrice: Yeah.
Right now, but it might not last.
>>Male Presenter: OK, right now.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: It's a wonderful book, Beatrice,
or Bea, is a wonderful person and I know you're
gonna enjoy this demo of one of the recipes
in the book which is a rice pudding with lemongrass.
>>Beatrice: We stew the strawberries with
lemongrass, lime and ginger.
>>Male Presenter: Afterwards there will be
time for Q and A, tasting, and book signing.
So, please join me in welcoming Bea.
[applause]
>>Beatrice: Thank you.
I'm very happy to be here.
The recipe I chose to demonstrate today with
you is a very simple one.
I'm sure that you all have already in your
repertoire rice pudding recipe.
This one is specific to me and is quite special
because in traditional recipes I typically
like to combine different flavors that can
be surprising and particularly here the lemongrass
that is going to be used to flavor the rice
as well as the strawberries.
So it is a very simple recipe.
Something that I think is always nice to make
at this time of year when you have seasonal
fruit like berries.
Here strawberries, but you could definitely
do that right now with rhubarbs and other
fruit.
And it's also a recipe you can do in the winter
when you have apples.
It's I think the quintessence of comfort food.
If you want my opinion.
So, the recipe has three major steps.
One, in which you're going to lightly toast
almonds.
These are sliced almonds.
You could also use slivered almonds.
I actually just recently found out that this
was called a sliced almond.
I used to think that they were slivered almonds.
So, always room to learn.
The second thing is, stewing the fruit, which
has been diced here finely.
The purpose here of dicing them finely is
so that specifically for small servings like
that, they actually gonna fit well the glass
I can use.
This is obviously a sampling portion.
But you can at home use small water glasses.
There are a great selection of glasses, I
don't know if I could say names, but Ikea's
got good ones.
And the third one is obviously the rice.
The rice takes the longest time, so I suggest
that you get it going and get--.
I mean, in the book, I actually mention doing
the almonds, the fruit and then the rice.
But you can really change the order as you
wish.
The recipe, I believe, is best eaten lukewarm.
But some prefer, and again that's a question
of preference, some people prefer when it's
cold.
Some people keep that in the fridge.
I, myself, like that when it's lukewarm.
So, you just choose again what's best for
you.
Bearing in mind that once the rice is cooked,
if you put it in the fridge, it's going to
thicken more and absorb more of the liquid.
Which is why my tendency goes to eating it
lukewarm, so
it's more of
the silky texture.
So let's get cooking.
So the first thing is, putting the fire on
your stove.
If I can do that.
Right.
So you just take those almonds and you put
them in your pan, making sure that you are
check regularly so that they just stay toasted.
So this is a very [inaudible] important thing
to do.
So, I would do like three to four, making
sure, once actually it starts getting brown,
you don't want to let it burn.
So you just really should not forget that
on the stove.
And the result is these things here.
Where are my almonds?
Here.
So this is what you end up having.
OK?
Just going to put that down.
And then turn the heat down.
I can't get that to simmer, but that's alright.
[chuckles]
The second thing is doing the strawberries.
So you take a big pot once you have diced
your strawberries, you put them in the pot
like this.
[thumping and clanging]
OK.
It's starting already here.
I have to keep an eye on this one because
I can't really turn that down, so.
Here you're gonna add some water, some sugar,
some lemon zest, lime zest, sorry.
Lemongrass.
You've all used lemongrass before.
No?
So the way to do it, you just remove the,
this very thick part.
Clean it as much as you can like this.
Watching my strawberries there.
See they're already burning.
So I'm gonna put them here.
So the lemongrass is like this.
You remove the thick part here.
And I'm going to cut in half.
Remove the hard part here.
And when it's just for the purpose of flavoring
something, you can basically just cut like
this.
And discard what you don't need.
For the purpose of the strawberries, you want
to be able to eat that, and obviously this
would not be very pleasant to eat.
So my trick to do this, you put the flavor
and not be annoyed by just eating pieces of
lemongrass like this.
I use a coffee grinder which is dedicated
to non-coffee flavored things.
[laughter]
And then you end up with something very, kind
of, a bit like hay.
Right.
But it's going to disintegrate.
And then you add a little bit of it.
In your pot.
[spoon clanging]
And then, you just put this to medium to low,
just a very gentle simmer.
And you're going to stew this very lightly
for five minutes maximum, because obviously
strawberries are very soft.
You want them to keep still their shape.
But still feel soft and stewy.
So just you know, stir like this.
[spoon clanging]
OK, so that's going.
It's very hot.
And the rice.
So the first thing is to take your milk.
So this is like two cups and a third of warm
milk.
The same little bit of lime.
And for this part, I actually do not mind
using like I said, this, because I will discard
it once the rice is cooked.
So, I add this to my pot and a piece of ginger.
So about an inch.
Again, doesn't matter how you slice it because
this will be discarded.
Like this.
[pause]
And you should actually get this to a boil.
So.
A pot.
[spoon clanging]
I'm going well so far?
[laughter]
OK.
So, test the strawberries maybe a little bit.
This heat is quite high, so I need to watch
it.
And what you need to do then is to prepare
your rice, so, this recipe or inside the book,
I actually mention carnaroli rice, which is
a type of risotto rice.
You could also use arborio, which might be
this one.
It doesn't really matter.
Some actually countries, I'm just back from
Ireland.
And I actually found a bag specific for rice
pudding.
Just to show you actually, that in some countries
rice pudding is just a whole institution.
[chuckling]
So just to prep it.
I suggest rinsing.
Rinsing the rice under cold water and once
your milk has reached boiling point, which
it will in a minute.
And this is way too hot already, so.
I am just removing that now.
So once this reaches boiling point, I'm going
just to slowly pour the rice in.
Lower the heat.
And stir regularly until most of the liquid
is absorbed.
So.
Tricky.
It's really hard to make that simmer, the
milk.
[sound of whisk in pot]
Alright.
Obviously, you do not want milk just to get
all over the pan.
This is a really good pan.
[spoon banging on pan]
OK.
So, this will take about 30 minutes.
And obviously for the purpose of this demo
I'm not gonna make you wait until the rice
is cooked.
[laughter]
It's just.
It's nice to see them actually.
Somehow, whenever I make this recipe I always
think "Oh, there's really too much liquid."
But it falls together.
So don't feel scared, that you think there's
too much liquid in comparison to how little
rice you put in.
Eventually it will come together.
And it's actually nice to keep it on the runny
side, because again, once it's cooling off,
cooling down, it will get thicker.
It's actually the same principle, if you've
ever made risotto.
You know, if you let it cool and sit, it will
get thick.
So.
So, I'm just stirring.
And [inaudible].
[clanging]
This is a real favorite at home.
So, we make that often.
[plastic crinkling]
OK.
Just coming back to this one.
And again, I just worry in the kitchen when
they were preparing, to burn it.
Meaning that you again, do not leave that
unattended, thinking you have other things,
it's going to happen on its own.
Sometimes, especially, depending on the kind
of pot you use, the heat is really, or if
the pot conveys much more heat than other
pots, you could actually end up with burned
rice.
It's best to go slower.
So put it on as low as you can.
As low as your stove can.
Rather than burn.
[spoon clangs on pot]
This is the rice that you end up having.
In this one, I already added the coconut milk
'cause at the end I finish with coconut milk
and sugar.
OK?
And I also have discarded in this one the
lemongrass and the ginger.
The lime stays in because it's been finely
chopped so it's been absorbed by the rice
again, so that you do not get tiny bits that
are uncomfortable to eat.
This is the rice.
You can see.
This one, I just prepared before coming here.
I'm gonna stop this because it's going—
[spoon banging on bowl]
And I like it at this temperature because
it's not too hot.
So, pretty much your recipe is done.
You have the rice pudding ready.
Sweetened.
Flavored with lemongrass and lime and ginger.
You have your stewed strawberries.
And the finishing touch is actually to take
the stewed strawberries here.
And that actually gives you this very lovely
juice, you know.
It's very nice.
And add some fresh ones for contrast of texture
and temperature.
So, typically, we'd let that cool a little
bit.
This is hot, obviously, but I'm going to do
that anyway.
Alright.
So again, you would do that with any kind
of fruit.
This is actually, by the way, lovely in the
morning too, if you like granola and plain
yogurt.
I always have a pot of these things in the
fridge for my breakfast in the morning.
So imagine you have a big serving glass.
And I am actually going to put it on the plate
here.
But you could serve it for more dressed up
dessert, again layered in a small glass.
Which is very lovely.
Or in a more rustic kind of way, you're going
to just plate your rice like this.
[pause]
[spoon clanking]
The fruit.
[pause]
And the toasted almonds.
And voila.
This is your rice pudding.
So, that's it.
[applause]
So, for you to sample here, I have small individual
portions.
And feel free just to have one, I'm just going
to pass it around.
Maybe you have questions as well, so I'm very
happy to answer questions about this recipe
or anything else about the book or whatever
you want to know.
Yes?
>>male #1: How hard is it to separate out
your ginger and lemongrass from the rice?
>>Beatrice: From the rice?
>>male #1: Yeah.
>>Beatrice: You mean, once it's cooked.
It's not.
Actually, what you need to do is like, it,
that's why I prefer to cut very thick piece
and not make it so small that you're not able
to find it in the rice.
So my way sometimes is even just to cut like
this, slice it, and then you just take, either
like a fork or what's that called?
Tongs?
And take it out.
Yeah?
This one is a little cold because I made it
last night, so.
If you want a warmer version I'm happy to
give you one as well.
Any other questions?
No?
Yes?
>>female #1: I was wondering what your favorite
recipe is.
>>Beatrice: Say that again?
>>female #1: I was wondering what your favorite
recipe is.
>>Beatrice: From the book?
>>female #1: Of course, they're all delicious.
>>Beatrice: Well, I really like them all.
I mean, they're all in the book for different
reasons.
And I think some of the favorites actually
are in the dessert, baking section, because
I love to bake.
Something that you also maybe might be curious
to know is that the book is all gluten free
so if it is something that you are actually
interested as well.
You know, like the muffins, the tart crusts.
Everything has been made with different kinds
of flour that I basically learned to use.
But the recipes are very much French inspired.
Because that's where I'm from.
But they are inspired by, my travels.
The fact that I lived in New Zealand.
Places like this.
So I like to take a French recipe that I know,
that I work with, and revisit it with my preferences
and flavors that I've learned to cook with.
Like, to this day, I don't believe that my
mother has ever cooked with coconut milk.
That's something that I learned by coming
outside the French countryside where it's
like more traditional, I suppose.
Do you like it?
[audience chatter]
>>Beatrice: Yes?
>>Female #2: Why did you decide to make gluten
free recipes?
>>Beatrice: Well, when I traveled to Peru,
many years ago I developed some stomach issues
that I basically couldn't identify.
And doing different research I just realized
I actually had the gluten intolerance.
So it was a bit of a challenge because being
French, we have the baguette, the bread.
But I was determined.
I thought, if this is the price to pay, I'm
going to try.
And in the end, came a wonderful enrichment
in my cooking repertoire, because I learned
to use flours that I didn't know much about.
Most of those flours also have much more nutrients,
protein.
So in the end, it made me a better cook, made
me a better baker.
It was challenging at the beginning, because
obviously, if you like to bake.
Especially I love to make tarts.
The French really love vegetable tarts.
The crust, if you just think about the ratio
that you are used to working with, and trying
to convert it to gluten-free flours, sometimes
it is crumbly, doesn't stay together.
So it's just basically, I had to learn to
create a lot of formula for what I knew how
to cook before.
So that's such, you know, and then, I could
have perhaps try to go back to eating with
gluten but I-- . First of all I felt so much
better.
That there was no question.
And then one thing I really enjoy is the flavors.
It became really a plus rather than a minus.
Yes?
>>male #2: Looking through the book initially,
I was like, wow, [inaudible], her food photography
is just awesome.
But I just, how did you learn food photography
and what got you into that?
>>Beatrice: Well, just by doing.
Like Jonathan said, you know I worked in a
completely different field before, but I was
always someone who was very much attracted
to visual arts.
And I love to cook.
So the day I decided to start a food blog,
funnily enough, the first article I ever wrote
was about food photography.
And I was fascinated, I remember, reading
about the fact that people had a profession
of food photographer.
So I thought "Wow, that's very cool."
So I did like perhaps a lot of people do.
When you want to do something, you just look
at who are the people you admire or what would
you like to achieve.
So I looked at the food magazines that I liked.
Because all along before even starting blogging
I had tons of, I was subscribed to so many
food magazines.
Like cookbooks, I had tons of cookbooks at
home.
And I just thought "OK, I like those pictures
and I want to be able to do that."
So I started with a point and shoot camera
which very quickly became a little frustrating
because I could not achieve the results that
I wanted.
And I moved to SLR.
And I did funnily enough, in my previous life,
I used to translate manuals.
And I used to hate to read manuals.
But when I bought my camera, I realized actually
the best way just to learn is just to read
the manual, you know, how to use this thing.
[laughter]
So it was bit of an irony because I used to
think nobody every reads those things.
[laughter]
You know, and I'm actually using them.
So I just worked hard.
I will say like really put a lot of my passion,
a lot of effort.
It's a trial and error process.
You know my first pictures are horrible.
But then I learned to understand light because
picture and specifically food photography
is all about the light.
But I exclusively choose natural light.
So I learned to know when is the best time
of the day to shoot.
And how to make food look yummy by working
with the light.
But it's basically, I'm completely self taught.
I think my passion was my drive.
And I love to cook and eat, so.
Thank you.
Yes?
>>female #3: I'm curious where you look for
inspiration.
For so long you've made many, many recipes
by now.
Where do you go to look for new inspiration
in your recipes?
>>Beatrice: Well, one of the things, I think
everyone I'm sure, when you do something a
lot, like you suggested you get saturated.
Obviously, I'm constantly in touch with trends,
or what other people do in magazines.
But my biggest actually inspiration is actually
traveling.
You know, whenever I travel, it's almost like
you break the pattern.
You just disconnect a little bit with this
kind of routine that you put yourself in.
And you know, like I said, I'm just back from
a trip to France and Ireland.
And even, like, of course here I eat very
similarly to the way I would eat in France,
but of course I have different ingredients.
I have different meals that I enjoy.
And when you go to people's house and then
all of a sudden this woman makes this granola
and you think "Oh, she make that.
And what's this in your granola?"
So it's just basically pulling inspiration
by being curious about what you eat.
You know, at other people's house, or in a
restaurant.
So it's a combination of those things and
like I said, I think travel is a big one.
Because it just gives me a different perspective
and understanding and trying to be creative
again.
That's it?
Yeah?
Well, thank you very much for coming.
[applause]